[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui est un grand jour nous
fêtons les 85 ans de maman et maman
comme toutes les mamans
elle est unique petit comité
mon frère ma soeur et son copain mon
mari et les enfants
je me suis levé à l'aube pour lui
concocter une journée sur mesure son
plat préféré mijote dans la cocotte
le champagne est au frais les petits
pour osho la table dressée musique
années 50
coussins sur sa chaise scrabble à portée
de main chauffage monte à 28
il me reste quelques bricoles et les
huîtres à ouvrir son péché mignon
mon mari est parti les chercher chez son
copain juste un aller retour et je les
ouvre qu'il m'a promis ça fait une heure
et demie mon frère salut frangine what u
est splendide
mais croire cette robe qui n'a qu'elle à
te mettre en plus j'ai vu ce matin sur
la mère ginette la vieille du cinquième
masters
bon ça m'a serais tu nous sommes un peu
en avance ça ne te dérange pas continue
de préparer on va se faire tout petit
dans le canapé
mon homme
tiens voici les huîtres extra frais de
man a fait goûter quelques unes mais
carrière de blanc au juste un petit os
allez je vais vite me raser je vais tout
ton ami paulette ces mamans je me sens
tendu colère tu me dérange
pourquoi es tu là que veux-tu me dire la
colère comme toutes les émotions est
involontaire je ne fais pas exprès
d'être en colère
elle est là lorsque nos limites sont
franchies
lorsque la qualité de la relation ne
nous convient pas et d'après les
résultats d'une étude récente menée sur
plus de 75 ans le bonheur n'est ni dans
l'argent ni dans la gloire ni dans la
quantité des amis sur les réseaux
le secret du bonheur c'est la qualité de
la relation et la colère c'est la
gardienne de la qualité de la relation
elle est là lorsque nous avons le
sentiment de recevoir un cactus
d'origines diverses parfois même
réactivant d'anciens cactus dont on n'a
même pas conscience
insultes trahison injustice coup
lorsqu'on s'attaque à nos proches plus
les cactus sont gros plus la colère est
facile à accepter car elle est visible
par tous
lorsque les cactus son petit moqueries
harcèlement tape sur les fesses
pincement pioche dans l'assiette c'est
plus compliqué on aurait même tendance à
se sentir coupable d'être en colère car
depuis des siècles on nous fait croire
que c'est mal
depuis platon une personne digne ne doit
pas montrer ses émotions
la colère comme elle est gardienne donc
de nos émotions comment faire revenons
aux 85 ans de maman pour mon frère
bader celui-là de te comparer à la
vieille du cinquième oh c'est pas
méchant c'est juste maladroit flatté et
caisses et juste après fait mal dit lui
qu'est ce qui va me répondre que je
comprends rien l'humour encore des
cactus dans votre relation bouche cousue
t'es foutu chute
c'est la fête de maman aujourd'hui
lorsque ma soeur s'en va dans le canapé
je me sens non respectés je me sens
abandonnée
la colère monte mais deux cerveaux se
déconnecte ait c'est sérieux sont
gonflés ces deux-là de te laisser tout
seul il pourrait t'aider
il ne reste que quelques choses à faire
et puis ils sont amoureux
l'amour ne justifie pas la politesse
fixe des limites
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont me répondre et
voilà la peur du regard des autres
bouche cousue des foutus c'est la fête
maman
aujourd'hui lorsque mon mari me ramène
les huîtres tard et qu'ils me laissent
les ouvrir tout seul mes limites sont
franchies
la colère monte mais deux cerveaux se
déconnecte ait c'est sérieux et voilà
comme d'habitude il traîne avec ton pote
et en plus il va te laisser ouvrir les
huîtres tout seul c'est déjà bien qu'ils
y soient déjà allés dis-lui que ça ne te
convient pas qu'est ce qu'il va me
répondre que je ne suis jamais contente
que je râle tout le temps bouche cousue
t'es foutu encore des cactus dans votre
relation
c'est la fête de mam aujourd'hui lorsque
nous choisissons de garder les cactus au
risque de s'accumulent ils risquent
d'exploser et cette explosion survient
souvent pour un petit cactus lancé la
plupart du temps perdre une personne
proche a non maman tu ne vas pas me dire
que tu n'es plus les autres tu ne peux
pas me faire ça cette personne que
j'aime que nous aimons ne comprend rien
à cette surréaction notre qualité de la
relation on souffre et nous souffrons
dès lors que cette qualité est malmené
lorsque nous choisissons de contenir
notre colère nous devenons lanceur de
cactus contre nous mêmes et nous
risquons d'imploser de nous faire mal
docteur je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
depuis les 85 ans de maman je me traîne
un terrible torticolis enfin lorsque
nous choisissons de terre notre colère
souvent par peur des réactions des
autres
par peur de leur regard nous ne donnons
pas l'occasion aux autres de nous
comprendre et de rectifier leur
comportement et il continue bouche
cousue nous sommes foutus qu'il est
difficile d'écouter sa colère elle n'a
pas bonne presse
gonflé à l'adrénaline elle déborde
d'énergie nous fait devenir agressif
exprimé avec violence elle fait peur à
juste titre car la violence entraîne
toujours la violence c'est destructeur
sous l'effet des neurones miroirs un
rapport de force créée dans la relation
c'est une ex calade
la colère est gardienne du respect
de la relation exprimé avec violence
elle est toxique réprimées elle l'est
tout autant voire pire
comment dompter son énergie comment
l'apprivoiser
comment en faire notre ami revenons aux
85 ans de maman pour mon frère a tu l'as
déjà vu sur moi je reste dans les faits
c'est normal c'est ma préférée
heureusement que tu me trouves jolie
dedans je positive et dis donc
la mère ginette elle a drôlement bon
goût j'utilise l'humour pour ma soeur
votre avance ne me dérange pas vous êtes
les bienvenus à la maison j'accueille il
me reste quelques bricoles à faire on
les fait ensemble en papotant je propose
pour mon mari ouf tu est sain et sauf
j'accueille
c'est vrai que les huîtres sont extras
et c'est vrai aussi que fred c'est un
sacré bavard je valide
j'aimerais vraiment que tu ouvre les
huîtres
j'informe et après on va se raser
ensemble j'utilise l'humour je me
blottis dans ses bras l'ocytocine une
des hormones du bien-être m'envahir la
colère descend je me détends le meilleur
antidote contre les cactus le cas là la
tendresse
je vous livre trois autres pistes pour
apprivoiser la colère cette émotion si
précieuse qui est garante du respect de
la relation ce qui est est le plus
important à choyer pour apprivoiser la
colère il est important
doté les cactus le plus vite possible
même les tout petits qui vont forcément
envenimer la relation pour apprivoiser
la colère il est important d'éviter au
maximum les critiques les plaintes les
reproches les encore jamais toujours ils
polluent la relation pour apprivoiser la
colère il est important de dédramatiser
sépare d'utiliser la bienveillance de
pratiquer l'amour et l'humour de
véritable boom pour la relation
je vais vous faire une confidence j'ai
grandi dans une famille experte en
lancer de cactus
vous savez une de ces familles issues
d'un village breton au fin fond de la
campagne un village de rebelles capable
de résister à l'envahisseur
certains membres de ma famille ont
tellement lancé accumulé de cactus qui
ne se voient plus ne se parlent plus
fâchés à mort
j'ai participé aussi à ses batailles et
puis j'en ai eu marre d'être piqué et
surtout j'ai eu la chance d'être
amoureuse d'un homme qui refuse de jouer
à ce jeu au début je comprenais pas
j'étais la seule à lancer rien en retour
il gardait tout en lui et puis j'ai
perçu sa souffrance insupportable je ne
pouvais pas être à l'origine de la
souffrance de mon aimé alors que le sens
même de mon métier de ma vie est de
soigner l'autre ça a été le déclic
il fallait que je change quelque chose
dans ma vie si je ne voulais pas vivre
avec un tas de cactus paul-jean mes
relations
lorsque j'ai compris que mes
sur-réaction l'expression de ma colère
de façon violente était liée à
l'accumulation de cactus
j'ai commencé par des friches et mon
jardin intérieur
j'ai ôté les épines parfois planté bien
profond je me suis fait aider pour
certaines pour d'autres j'ai même dû m'y
reprendre à deux fois
et puis j'ai travaillé je me suis
entraîné parce que c'est difficile
d'exprimer sa colère avec tact et les
vieux démons revenant vite au gallon
j'ai cherché une astuce d'une touche une
touche utilisé par le monde entier
une touche utilisé par la majorité
d'entre vous ce soir la touche
informatique halte c'est sérieux
lorsque la colère monte j'utilise ce
moyen mémo technique ait c'est sérieux à
pour accepte us accepter parfois je me
sens blessé
je suis en colère elle du mot langage
logo russe m'entraîner à l'exprimer avec
le plus de tact possible le plus
d'humour possible tpour trait aux russes
notre trésor et la qualité de la
relation aux autres
elle doit être choyés c'est pour
conectus me connecter avec ce qui me
fait du bien
la nature l'écriture les amis pour me
remplir d'énergie positive de très bon
bouclier contre la colère s pour ce
marin russe on est là pour rigoler
cultiver notre joie avec beaucoup de
bienveillance d'humilité de respect je
vous invite à vous poser la question et
moi j'en suis avec les cactus où j'en
suis avec la colère
je suis convaincu que si chacun d'entre
nous fait sa part pour apprivoiser sa
colère l'exprimé avec le plus de tact
possible l'accepter l'écouté si chacun
d'entre nous c'est sa part pour la
prendre à nos enfants à nos petits
enfants nos relations seront apaisées et
nous serons plus heureux transformons
nos cactus en lotus et de la colère
naîtra la paix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]